hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys wels
heute gibt's einen kuchen rezept oder
backofen das heißt wieder einen no way
touren
ich werde heute einen mosaik kuchen
machen und zwar inspiriert von unserem
urlaub wir haben dort nämlich in der
türkei immer gerne sind muss der kuchen
gegessen
im prinzip ist es so was wie der kalte
hund nur ein bisschen anders da werden
die sechs schichten nicht geschichte
sondern sie werden zerbröselt und beim
aufschneiden es gibt eben aussehen muss
sagen ich kann mich wirklich nicht
ja ich war noch denn ich habe ihn dort
wirklich fast jeden tag gegessen
das ist doch irgendwie madonna hat die
frau hat immer gerne gemacht
naja jedenfalls ist der kuchen wirklich
sehr lecker ihr braucht nur wenige
zutaten und man kann ihn auch auf vorrat
herstellen denn manfred in kuchen ein
und kann das bei bedarf immer eine
scheibe runter schneiden schweizer
wurstscheibe sie sich doch mal was
jedenfalls hat man immer was da und hat
auch immer was für seine gäste also ich
starte jetzt uns zeigt euch mal die
zutaten dafür brauche ich 350 gramm
butter keksen 200 gramm mills 60 gramm
kakaopulver und dann jeweils 100 gramm
zucker butter bei der schokolade
gestiftete mandeln und kokosraspeln ich
werde zuerst einmal die zutaten in einen
topf geben ihr braucht dafür auch
wirklich gar kein richtiges werkzeug
sondern nur stand dazu gehören jetzt
kommt zur fdp hier ein gemeinsames und
das ganze wird es erstmal hilft auf etwa
mittlerer stufe also es muss nicht auf
kochen mit dem butter muss einfach nur
schmelzen
das hat die mutter
die butter sogar könnt ihr auch gleich
mit dazu geben und kakaopulver 80
schokolade gebe ich auch gleich gesagt
so da kann ich gleich alles verrühren
bei der mathe müsst ihr darauf achten
dass sie wirklich nicht zu heiß wird und
jetzt will ich sie in ein großes
schildchen um ist eine große schale
da kommen jetzt die gestifteten mandeln
mit rein und die haben eben dann richtig
schönen mann kann jetzt auch vorher noch
wolfskin wenn man möchte muss man aber
nicht die schmecken auch so richtig gut
jetzt kommt noch die butterkekse mit
rein und anders als beim kalten hund
werden die jetzt da nicht geschichte
sondern die werden jetzt zerbröselt so
ein bisschen zerkleinert und dadurch
entsteht dann später dieser mosaik
effekt am besten jetzt nicht zaudern
sondern einfach nur kurz mit den händen
zerbröseln und das rechnung auch schon
schlesier zutaten ganz gut vermischen so
dass wirklich alle kekse mit der
schokolade bedeckt sind
nächstes die masse fertig und kann
bereits getroffen werden
warum von einer klar ist wer in der
hölle wenn ich kann man als extrakt
benutzen wird also wer möchte gibt
einfach noch ein bisschen war in exakt
motto lasst diesen vanille geschmack
kurz berühren und dann ist die masse
fertig jetzt könnt ihr sie formen und
braucht dafür einfach nur etwas
frischhaltefolie die breite ich jetzt
hier auf
und gibt da die ganze masse drauf
jetzt klappte die beiden langen teil das
so
und nehmen wir uns am besten eine
kastenform zu hilfe oder wenn ihr keine
kastenform hat einfach irgendeine andere
form oder ihr macht auch komplett ohne
form also das geht auf jeden fall auch
legte jetzt da rein und formen sie dann
noch schön können dass entweder so
lassen so einer rolle formen oder zum
beispiel zu einer pyramide wo ich werde
selbst und pyramide formen daher ganz
kurz mal und dann einfach einlegen
und dann wieder zurück in die form legen
einfach noch ein bisschen nach drücken
und im prinzip ist der kuchen jetzt
schon fertig ich musste jetzt nur noch
einfrieren für mindestens drei bis vier
stunden und dann zeige ich euch das
ergebnis
jetzt mal ein paar stunden ist der
kuchen ist eingefroren
jetzt bin auch mal gespannt wie das ist
ja ein aussehen stück fleisch aber nicht
im vorteil sind
so jetzt auspacken und wie gesagt die
form können wir machen wie ihr möchtet
und falls ihr diese dreieckige form
nicht auf anhieb so gut hinbekommt
könnte es ja auch zum beispiel alle
halbe stunde immer mal noch mal nach
vorne und dann wird es auch ein bisschen
einfacher
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt und ich habe
den schon mal gegessen ja in der türkei
im urlaub habe denke ich komme mir ein
bisschen kokosraspeln drauf da kann man
so ein bisschen drin werde sind also bei
möchte man muss natürlich nicht das ist
optional
schon nicht mehr daran erinnern und ich
finde den kuchen halt super weil man
toll vorbereiten kann
und meint dann einfach im gefrierschrank
aufheben kann also im prinzip hat dort
immer und fertigen kuchen war
den rest kann man natürlich aufheben und
jetzt schneide ich hier gleich wer doch
nur was runter also es ist keine
eisstock doch im prinzip eigentlich fast
ein bisschen wird unser tool oder
dadurch dass wir eben diese kekse
verkleidet haben sie das eben aus dem
reichstag und musik klingt logisch
den setzte jetzt mal hier drauf das ist
hübsch aussieht im bild so dazu ich
meine dazu nämlich natürlich in
typischen schwarzen wie das aussieht ich
erstmal so in die kamera gemacht richtig
cool doch das ist richtig toll aus also
im prinzip ist ja wie ein kalter hund
also man kennt ja auch das dass er den
kuchen kalte hund das machen ganz viel
auch ganz viele verschiedene abend
weisen manche machen es mit avanti mit
schokolade manche mit cacau bei manchen
ist nur schokolade und butter drin und
es sieht so eine abwandlung als mosaik
und ohne ein natürlich finde ich das ja
nicht noch besser und ich finde mit ganz
einfachen zutaten genau ihren kalter
hund ist in china was ganz anderes
wahrscheinlich ja auf jeden fall darf
sich ist hier auch für glas aus dazu
noch ein tee oder espresso zuschauern
ging recht gespannt und co
ok ich probiere jetzt mal
und vielleicht mehr einführen dass wir
es auch tun
das erinnert mich irgendetwas vielleicht
einfach urlaub
ja und zwar endlich das hätten vom
geschmack herren irgendetwas ich kann es
nicht sein hat irgendwas von magnum kann
kein spiel auch schon jetzt hat und was
vielleicht wegen den mandelsplitter ja
auf jeden fall die kokons mitmachen das
ist nicht richtig cool
zumal man ja und wie finde ich es ok
vorn genial ich habe es echt gedacht
dass selbst stamme zugefroren genau dass
ich das so hart gefahren das
unterscheidet den ja auch dann liegt da
ganz kurz und dann hatte ich die
optimale temperatur zu messen hat auch
irgendwas von einem braun ja stimmt die
statiker hatte schokolade und kakao drin
war wirklich cool sind nach machen ob
ich okay also falls ihr es noch dieses
rezept bekommen habt habt dann jedoch
ließ - lockt der etat steht es noch mal
für euch und ich wünsche euch schon mal
ganz viel spaß beim nachbacken und ich
werde auf jeden fall noch eine andere
variante davon machen wahrscheinlich
nämlich als weißen macbook air ist noch
richtig mächtig als ich immer zwei
stunden zwei stücke junger ein stück ist
schon gut ich habe jetzt zwei drauf
klickt wird aber nicht auch wenn also
bis zum nächsten mal
also ich es alles für dich in einer von
hunderten 1 homeserver an und machen es
für mich jetzt